There's an old saying in AI,
which goes like, if you have the right knowledge representation,
problem solving becomes very easy. Let's see whether that also works here.
We now have a knowledge representation for this problem of guards and prisoners.
Does this knowledge representation immediately afford effective problem solving?
So, here we are in the first node, the first state. There are three guards and
three prisoners in the boat, all in the left-hand side. Let us see what moves
are possible from this initial state. Now, using this representation, we can
quickly figure out that there are five possible moves from the initial state.
And the first move, we move only guard to the right. On the second move,
we move a guard and a prisoner to the right. In the third move, we can move two
guards, or two prisoners. Or, in the fifth move, just one prisoner to the right.
Five possible moves. Of course, we know that some of these moves are illegal and
some of them are likely to be not very productive. Will the semantic network
allow us to make inferences about which moves are productive and
which moves are not productive? Let's see further. So, let's look at
the legal moves first. So we can immediately make out from this representation,
that the first move is not legal because we are not allowed to
have more prisoners than guards on one side, of the river.
Similarly, we know that the third move is illegal for the same reason.
So, we can immediately rule out the first and the third moves. The fifth move,
too, can be ruled out. Let's see how. We have one prisoner on the other side.
But the only way to go back would be to take the prisoner to the,
back to the previous side. And if we do that, we reach the initial state.
So we did not make any forward progress. Therefore, we can rule out this move
as well. This leaves us with two possible moves that are both legal and
productive. The, we have already removed the moves that were not legal and
not productive. Later, we will see how AI programs can use various
methods to figure out what moves are productive and what moves are unproductive.
For the time being, let's go along with our problem solving.